la fête du pain sa consommation a été
divisé par six en un siècle mais il
reste une passion française
nouvelle preuve s'il en faut le pain
fabriqué à la maison fait un tabac grâce
à la commercialisation de nouvelles
machines sophie mais elle marie cazaux
avant pour faire son vin ça demande un
peu d'entraînement maintenant plus
besoin de le mériter
en une minute le tour est joué
explication c'est simple on mélo d'abord
le liquide
ensuite la farine plus une cuillère de
sel et une autre de levure la map la
machine à pain en dehors de son petit
coeur qui bat quelques arguments le
teint pour le petit déjeuner la brioche
pour le goûter des enfants une brioche
un pain aux chèvres pour un apéro pour
le pique nique
on peut même faire la pâte à pizza donc
pas si sympa quand on aime le pain bon
c'est vrai que ça fait pas les
paillettes et trois heures plus tard
voilà le résultat pour moins d'un euro
électricité comprises l'amap c'est le
phénomène du moment des dizaines de
références et une offre en constante
évolution de 59 à 159 euros
le match n'a pas est un marché qui
avoisine les 300 350 mille pièces à
l'année alors qu'il y a deux ans ça
marche et qui qui tournait à moins de
200 une pièce l'engouement est tel que
des tchats spécifiques se sont créés sur
la toile pour échanger qu' une recette
qui une photo de son oeuvre d'art
l'édition s'est aussi emparé du
phénomène avec une vingtaine de titres à
ce jour dont quelques best-sellers
cinquante mille exemplaires pour cet
éditeur qui n'en revient toujours pas de
son succès c'est pas forcément très
facile de faire une recette à la machine
à pain c'est peut-être aussi ce qui
explique le succès du livre c'est à dire
qu'il vaut mieux avoir des vraies
recettes des recette éprouvée et testée
et faciles à réaliser
encore faut-il que le pain soit ben
voilà l'objet donc nous sommes allés le
faire tester par un boulanger de renom
manque un peu de fermentation à mon goût
mais jean c'est lui qui leur a fait il
sera le meilleur du monde parce que ça
sera sans pain
et peu importe si les maps lui font
concurrence ou dit le boulanger tout ce
qui rapproche du goût du pain est bon
pour le métier